voilà monsieur bonsoir c'est une
première qui vient d'avoir lieu à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris une nouvelle avancée de la
vidéochirurgie un pontage coronarien
sans ouverture de l'intérieur grâce
notamment à une mini-caméra matuchet
frédéric bazille
opéré pendant plus de trois heures hier
soir cet homme de 50 ans se rétablit peu
à peu il a subi une opération grave un
pontage coronarien une opération rendue
nécessaire quand le sang ne circule plus
bien dans les artères du coeur si ce
patient ne peuvent pratiquement aucune
cicatrice c'est qu'il a bénéficié d'une
toute nouvelle technique une mini caméra
qui évite d'ouvrir l'autorail est simple
dans l'enceinte technique on ouvre le
thorax on arrête le coeur avec ce
nouveau procédé le thorax n'est
pratiquement pas ouvert et le coeur
n'est pas arrêté
on fait deux petits trous pour
introduire les caméras et les outils et
c'est à travers ces trous qu'on réalise
l'opération chaque année 25 mille
malades sont opérés en france d'un
pontage coronarien expérimenté depuis 18
mois sur des animaux la méthode de
vidéos chirurgie est aujourd'hui au
point et présente de nombreux avantages
les premiers avantage c'est qu'on peut
espérer que cette technique sera
beaucoup moins douloureux que le
comptage traditionnel petite incision
dans moins de douleur qu'il pourrait
mobiliser plus rapidement et que son
séjour à l'hôpital sera beaucoup plus
courte durée mais attention précise les
médecins cette technique ne fait que
débuter et ne pourra pas remplacer
immédiatement
l'opération classique plus douloureuse
mais beaucoup moins complexe